alright well thanks everybody for
getting up on a Sunday morning I'm very
impressed I'm very happy to be here this
is my first part data and I think it's
really a vibrant community it's really
great to be here and so thanks a lot to
the organizers I think especially yet in
for setting up the meeting and inviting
me so um I put up this title and now I
look at it and I have to live up with
the promise I gave you so that's kind of
a challenge just the disclaimer this
talk is as much about people in project
as it's about couldn't algorithm it's
not only a technical talk so to set the
problem I did a PhD in quantum physics
nothing related to algorithms or machine
learning it was more about a vacuum
systems which means leaks electronics
which means shorts and lasers which
means injecting fibers horrible things
it was actually great training for a jaw
like project management because you know
you got short time around short cycles
and things fail so computers were part
of the game but there were only one part
of the game the kind of things that we
were doing was coding in matlab and c
and eventually bitin at the end and
mostly experimental control software and
data data processing and the reason I'm
mentioning this is that really shaped my
vision about computing and software as a
tool that is there to serve a purpose
it's not a names by itself so if we fast
forward to 2011 I kind of switch gears
in the meantime and I was recruited as a
teenager researcher in computer science
at in area which is the French a
computer science research and that was a
huge deal for me because and I mean I
really look up doing that yeah I think
it's a great institution it does a
combination really babe
from the mantle research in computer
science and great applications and great
software so that's really the place why
I want it to be and nowadays well I have
a growing team that focuses on some
applications of data sciences and I'm
really happy to say that we're starting
to be recruiting pretty good people and
for instance our last recruitment was
edgy crazy who you might know so we're
starting to have a pretty solid team so
that's really great so what do we do
were uninterested in using machine
learning kind of methods to understand
brain function I'm going to give a bit
more details but the idea is that we're
going to try to link basics thing oh
yeah that's not going to work that's
going to we're going to try to link a
basic neural activity to cognition and
thought so that's very well defined and
that's the gene general setting the way
we're going to do this is that we're
going to use functional MRI so
functional MRI uses a standard scanner
like you have in every single hospital
and it records the brain activity office
subject time-resolved spatially resolved
brain activity subject so you get a
movie of the brain activity of the
subject sure thank you so yeah that's
that's the day they will work with and
our big goal is that of what's known as
cognitive near imaging and the idea is
that we want to learn a bilateral link
between brain activity as we see it in
facial imaging and cognitive function
where cognitive function is an
ill-defined concept in we can tackle
this with machine learning and one
problem that we can that we can write as
a machine learning problem as what's
known as encoding models so the idea is
that you're going to start from the
description of the stimuli and you're
going to try
predict the neural response so the brain
activity so that's the machine learning
problem that i can i can solve it's
interesting because it gives us a window
into the brain representation of the
stimuli so good model that is able to
predict well the stimuli probably has a
good description of the external world
so you can see this feature engineering
a description of the world that matches
our brain another problem that we can do
is what's known as decoding so decoding
is the inverse problem you're starting
to predict you trying to predict the
stimuli from the brain activity so it's
a brain reading like problem it always
gets you know great traction in in the
newspapers you see old people were able
to decode dreams so what this really is
is the data processing challenge and so
for instance if we take a visual stimuli
in 2008 there was a Japanese group who
was able to show some pretty impressive
stuff where they would do visual image
reconstruction from the activity in the
human visual cortex so they would look
at the human visual cortex and they will
they be able to predict somewhat what
people saw so that was a feat it was a
tour de force the problem is I don't
think science should be tour de force I
think it should be reproducible and this
is a citation by Victoria Snowden who is
big on reproducible science and she says
that it needs to be open and verifiable
by others so the way I put it is that
this is software this is data processing
SAR software we want to make it work
first make it right second and then I
want to make it boring you know it's
when something is worse ringing out of
the box when it's routine then you
forget about it and it's boring and I
want you know things like visual image
reconstruction
to be boring so we're getting there
you've got a code example on the web
that you can download the slides are
going to be on the way I'm going to put
them on SlideShare so you can download
it and you can rent it and it's going to
fetch the data from this experiment and
it's going to ran classifiers and it's
going to produce images like this so
this is the stimuli that was presented
to the subject this is what we
reconstructed and this is the binarized
version so this you can run so this is a
goal we want the code the data to be
available and things to just work out of
the box so this is a new project that
I'm starting to invest in that we've
started in our group that's that we call
911 for your imaging learn and this is a
software development challenge you know
we need we're taking a science problem
paper and we want this to be completely
reproducible make you happy you can use
it you can use them on new data all
right that's software once this work
well we can be new things and if we are
able to do a data processing as a
routine then we can throw in more data
so then we're going into the direction
of big data so super training stuff why
we're interested in this is because
we're going to be able to learn richer
models of brain function you not only
visual image reconstruction but
detecting the type of object or the
emotion all this in one model so that's
super challenging but I'm very excited
about this pictures what we're getting
at is accumulation of scientific
knowledge so basically all those
experiments and to learn formal
representations are this knowledge so
the predictive model works not on
concepts but on representations of these
concepts and so I think this is really
excited because I think we're getting at
the core of what science is and this is
a citation by Stephen Hawking and he
says that a good theory must accurately
described large glasses of observations
and may
definitely predictions about the results
of future observations okay that's
machine learning I've got you know
trainer tester so what I'm getting there
what I'm getting at is I think we're
going to be facing more and more of this
which is data-driven science and it's
not only about you know minimizing an
error it's about understanding things
and using machine learning and I think
that's super exciting because this is
the future and so that's the reason I
mean I'm in the business of cognitive
near imaging because I think those new
tools not tomorrow but in ten years will
be shaping what we do in cognitive your
engine problem is on a day to day basis
I'm bothered by you know minor minor
details like the fact that we buggy code
or slow code or that my main data
scientist might leave or that I've got
new interns to trade or actually that I
don't understand the code that I've
written a year ago so you know in a way
a lab is not much different from any
other startup or technical and either
you know you have difficulties and
you've risks difficulties are recruiting
you all know it's really hard to record
good people the fact that you've got
limited resources whether it's people
are hardware and the risks well I want
to point out to read important risks
that were all facing one is the best
factor so the best factor is how many
people it takes to be hit by a bus for
your project to stop that's really
important in a mini mini labs or
startups or software project have a bus
factor of one you know if one critical
person disappears that thing stops in
actually I think that this so this is
like a sick joke but I think it took
another since two years ago when we lost
Jenna hunter so John Hunter was the
creator of matlab and so he died two
years ago cancer it was very quick I
mean we lost them really quickly and it
was a big hit on all of us because he
was a friend
and so that's the sad part the great
part is you know Matt partly is a
striving project even without John
because he built it right so any we joke
about these things but if you want if
you want your projects whether their
startup whether their software project
just survive you because say because
you've got kids and you move on in life
you need to think about these things
another really important problem is that
of technical debt so technol that is say
I code my project I built my starter
really really fast I don't worry about
you know getting the co tried getting
the minor details right well at some
point this is going to catch up with me
it's just like my car if I don't do them
in canyons of my car and it's going to
fail at some point I'm going to have to
buy a new car or change the engine
that's a big risk and people keep
falling in it so I think these are the
two risks I'm most worried about so if
we go back to my mission is as an
academic I need to revolutionize bring
data processing this is what I'm here to
do but actually have you know very tight
budget you know spending and science
blah blah blah and and I'm quite aware
of the problems so let's try to take a
step back and think about what kind of
patterns always seen our data processing
first let's try to look at a workflow a
workflow is mostly a jacked a bit with
data right or script to do this
interaction and then hopefully you know
turn this into module what the set of
functions are useful once I've got this
module well I can appoint to new data or
the old data and I can keep going so
there's this like this iteration
hopefully and that's really important
iteration goes with consolidation else
where you're going to be accumulated in
technical debt and I want this to be a
jhalak which I which means I want this
to be low-tech because I have a low
budget now once they have short
turnaround times that's the workflow and
something I've seen in science but also
in the industry is that were slowly
switching from statistics to statistical
learning so statistical learning is
machine learning with a statistical
flavor and it's a paradigm shift that's
driven by the growing dimensionality of
the data not only in terms of number of
samples but also in terms of number of
features so how many descriptors you
have for each sample and the reason is
that sensors in a general sense things
like you know a web page is a sensor
nowaday a phone is as a sensor
everything is a sensor everything
gathers data so we're all trying
starting to have much much more data
it's cheap it's noisy its high
dimensional so we're going from this
picture of you know I've got a bunch of
points and I fit a model into it and
then I look at how well the model fits
to one that is more interested in
prediction and prediction from high
dimensional problems so we're looking
needle and haystack problems alright so
that's the picture we've got plenty of
problems let's just make software to
solve these problems so then we're going
to have one more problem so making
software on more and more basing it on
simple design philosophy that I've tried
to summarize here first point is I don't
try to solve hard problems you know hot
problems are hard and I try to solve my
original problem and I try to make sure
that I'm not solving a problem that's
hotter than my original problem once
only marginal problem software needs to
be easy to set up and to work out of the
box which means I'm low in dependencies
I want a conventions over configuration
you know default parameters elsewhere I
won't have any users and that includes
my students that will not use my
software software should fail gracefully
you know software fails that's a fact
but it should try to fill as well as
possible and when fields it should be
understandable wide field that's really
important I think that's one of the
major keys of success of Python for
advanced user debugging python is much
easier than the begging see and then
lost quality software is about quality
if you don't do a high quality software
you won't have any users therefore why
are you doing software you might as well
you know do something else final note
don't try to build a big software that's
going to solve all the problems it's
it's not going to work because a you're
going to solve all your problems and not
on your neighbors problem and be you're
going to be the only one who has the
expertise to track this software and
that's really important you're building
yourself a best-actor one you break down
your problems into projects that require
different expertise and then try to
build software on each of these projects
so so I could learn on one of the
original core developers of scikit-learn
and I am somewhat the project ahead of
psychic learn so you all know about so I
could learn I'm not this is not a
tutorial in cycling i'm not i'm assuming
that you know basic things about about
scikit-learn the vision of the project
is to have a machine learning tool box
that can be used by people who are not
machine learning experts when we started
people with tell me with jealousy add
it's not an interesting problem we want
in advanced machine learning tool box
not simple things so we want a black box
that can be open that's why we're in
piketon that's why we have objects
they're fairly simple that you can open
them and combine them so it's finding
the right trade-off between what just
works in what's versatile and you can
think Apple versus linux and I've seen a
bunch of geeks as they grow old there
start having you know I phones and an
apple computers so you know things just
working matter a lot so we're not going
to solve all the problems for you
remember I don't solve hard problems so
things like feature engineering domain
specific cases we
not gonna sell them for you the good
news is that python is a turing-complete
imperative programming language so you
know you've got these set of tools and
you can you can step class an estimator
you can you can write your own code and
that's for me that's very important in
the design of socket learning is that
I'm not going to go out of my way to
solve every user's problem elsewhere i'm
just going to have a complete spaghetti
code that doesn't that is
incomprehensible so we want to cover all
the eighty percent use cases in one
single package that's the goal so if i
try to look back and think what have we
done right in scikit-learn well i think
one thing that we've done right is to
stick as much as possible to high-level
programming this is what has been
keeping us afloat we have a ridiculous
number of contributors we give huge
activity pole rechristened bug reports
all the time the only thing that is
preventing us from dying under under the
load is the fact that we're as high
level as possible so how do you stay
performance in be high level because I
think we're reasonably performance and
so the secret sauce is you want to
optimize algorithms not for Lou not
low-level optimization that's really
important you should perfectly know
numpy inside by perfectly I'm not
kidding any significant data should be a
raise or memory reviews and people are
going to tell me yes but I've got a
bunch of strings I don't know how to do
this their ways around this you know
other things like the featuring hasher
and scikit-learn you just try to find a
way to put your date sat in arrays
continues blocks of memories basically
and then avoid memory copies and rely on
no level numerical libraries like glass
or land back so oh great you can't at
all see the light gray so you can't see
what's here so your tools are and even
mentioned it line profiler and memory
profiler to understand this better in
that's one of my own pet projects but
the syfy lecture notes give you
a lot of information on numpy site by
how to optimize cone and basically if
you know them all then you're pretty
good last but not least we try not to do
any compiled code sometimes we have to
then we use seitan we don't use C or C++
a lot of us came code in C or C++ even
though I tend to forget we don't use it
siphon is more maintainable and each
time a new contributor comes in there's
a bit of a fight he's like yeah but
slight then you know I know see we're
really happy about this really happy in
the long term so just to give you an
example rather than talk abstract I'm
going to talk about the pull request is
I've been working on for the last what a
year and a half tells you I'm getting
old and I don't have enough time to to
code so the idea is that we're going to
implement hierarchical clustering and
the core idea is that we're going to
loop on taking the two closest clusters
given a certain distance merge them and
update the distance matrix so we're
building you know hierarchically
agglomerative lee out of clusters so the
interesting thing is that this kind of
clustering is actually faster when you
have constraints because then you can go
to sparse distance matrix first times
like second insight is well I'm going to
keep you know taking the minimum of this
distance matrix hmm maybe you can use a
heap q heat Q is a data structure that
will keep its minimum always really
easily together you know you add
something to it and it reorders to have
the minimum so that's one way of
avoiding in the computing the minimum on
the whole data matrix all the time so
that's already your huge gain when you
do this you know python has a HEPA Q
module so you're fine in game to keep
the neighborhood information we needed a
sponge coral structure so that's tricky
so I thought hey skip lists skip lists
or a probabilistic data structure there
are somewhat in between trees and lists
they're super sexy they're using things
like I think they're using Revit I was
like I want a code is Skip list so i
could add a skip lyst insight that that
was super challenging you
pointer and mythic and memory allocation
and took me a while it was super proud
so it's got a log an insert removable
random axes great and then I realized so
that was really tricky code and then I
realized you know c++ map construct
that's pretty much what I need and then
I can wrap it in sight then with a
couple hundred lines of sight and code
and gives me pretty much all this that's
an interesting way I mean interesting
story of are we going to super complex
things and then we figure out once we
understand our problems we can do it
very very simply so all this code bang
thrown away so this is how we get
superfast hierarchical clustering and
hopefully we're going to merge this
student all right so I could learn
something I think that's really
important from the API design so I think
people kind of like this like a learning
API I'm going to give you a bit the ID
that are behind the secular n'ap I and
one of the qualities is that when a
separate data from operations so if it
is this you've got an agent that you
know walks around the data and that
agent is your operation so that's the
conceptual a picture and if you look a
bit its its presence in boquete maybe a
bit hidden but its present there at was
present in Chaco before it's quite
gloomy present in Hadoop but it's also
hidden behind Miami and it's also in
CPUs you know CPUs you've got the cash
and you've got the registries that's a
fairly generic pattern even though it's
hidden everywhere it's also hidden in
psychic learn so I'm going to show you
how its present in scikit-learn and the
reason it's hidden is that we really
wanted to keep it into an imperative
like language you know a declarative
programming as in I list I described the
operations I'm going to do is great from
the figure a same point but it just
doesn't match the way the brain works so
we have a core object API that exposes a
small data processing language
and if you probably knew it its fit
predict transforms core partial fit I
may be forgetting things but not much
this is a core grammar and we can do a
lot of things with this these objects
are insensitive without the data but
with all the parameters and that's
really important that's what means that
they can ever live a life of their own
that's detached from the data so that
was a really critical a design decision
and then we've got objects like by
binding or merging to be able to build
something richer so this pattern of
objects are instantiated without the
data but with all the Premier's there
need you can think of it as the
configuration run pattern that is
present in things like traits or pyre
pyre was a framework by my couch by
jesus at the Cal Tech Center for
Advanced Research computing and I had a
lot of discussion with my phone and so
all these frameworks whether it's pyar
or traits they're they're heavy
frameworks they force you to do things
we've done this by convention you know
you can write a crappy a circular object
that don't respect these conventions
there's nothing in the framework that
forces you not to do do this it's just
us when we review your progress we're
going to tell you now this is all so
basically what sin is a curie in
functional programming so for those who
don't know this it's basically fun tool
partial so I'm just taking a function
that has parameter is that in and add
and takes data and i'm just going to
partial out all the parameters then the
function only takes the data and you can
link it remotely jollies from the MVC
pattern so just to show you that you
know api's are they're not designed out
of nowhere even though they seem simple
all right how are we going to do big
data and small hard work because I don't
have a budget only have small hardwood
well actually we're going to do bikash
day they're not really really big lead
and we're going to use smaller strong
word although I do have users that
really want to use MacBook Air to
process dirty I'm not kidding they
really want it and they're not
processing their data now so what we
don't want to use those hedrick i'm
sorry i'm not using Hadoop it's named
for huge datasets man it's for
distributed storage computing clusters I
don't have these problems I have
gigabytes terabytes nowadays I want to
do by thing that's really important I
don't want mine students do you have to
learn multiple languages and learn
debugging and being productive in
multiple languages and I want to use of
the Shelf commodity hardware that's
really important i think that's ninety
nine percent of the problems that are
copied like this all right i still want
to be efficient on biggest data so one
important trick is to use Watson is
online algorithms so online algorithms
they process the data in one sample at a
time and to give you an example if I'm
asking you to compute the mean of a
gazillion numbers is that hard that's
not I mean I just do a running mean okay
they're going to be difficulties with
rounding errors but running mean is
going to be able to take as much data as
you want right that's the co ID you've
got an algorithm that converges in
general it converges only with high
probability to expectations of
statistical properties of your data
which is just moving around and
eventually converging as it seems more
data the way we implement this is that
we used the mini batch trick which is
that we're going to bunch observation
together to be able to have any good
vectorization and one example is k-means
clustering so i'm going to apply this on
a fairly small matrix which is a 10,000
samples and 200 features and i'm going
to compare the syfy k-means where the
circuit learn mini batch k-means and
we've kind of judah per meter so that
they were reasonably comparable side
politics 11 seconds second learning
takes less than one second it really
what makes the difference is that this
is I'm in a batch algorithm I could
crank up the sample size and it would
get even worse just you know I hear a
lot of people telling me how they need
to have distributed array operations on
a cluster to be able to add together
arrays
that have petabytes of data I'm like no
I don't need I can do this all the
important trick what I call on the
flight data reduction big data or
biggest it is very often I abound so
you're going to want to have something
that you can run prior to data analysis
or in parallel with your DNA analysis
that it reduces your data if you have a
lot because you're going to optimize
things like CPU cache Ram you're going
to optimize the use of here and local
this were with regard to distance Tory
edge also stupid the true if you have
less data it's easier to run the
algorithms so the simplest way to do
this is just drop data and for instance
you can you know in a loop take a random
fraction of the data and running
algorithm on that fraction and then you
do this several times and then you
aggregate at the results across the
different sub samplings as long as the
algorithms that you're running our
superlinear on the sample size this is
going to be useful and the reason it's
worse is that it is poised to fact that
you tend to have redundancies across
observations and if you can run this
loop in parallel then you've got a
double win ok so in cycler we've got a
bunch of ways of doing faster data
reduction things like random projections
or clustering features if you've got
images this can work fantastically well
or hashing so you can turn you know text
into a hash that then is much more it
also fits in in a given memory slot so
then you can work with a raise use these
and to give you an example of these
trick it's the randomized SVD I mean the
render my SS VD that's just a random
like this video so you can invite like a
normal SVD but inside those tricks like
using random projection like approach
and so here I've compiled it on once
again actually not terribly big data set
and I've compared it to my lay back
solver that takes six
seconds the rpac solvers so that's a
poet ocean method asking for the 10
biggest augen values or single values
that's 2.5 second and the randomized SVD
takes point 3 second and so you're like
okay but that's an approximate solution
right so then I'm going to look at the
error between lay back and our pack and
lay back in our solution well our
solution is actually absolutely closer
to lay back in our back so it's a pretty
good solution so randomized data
redactions can work pretty well all
right talking about hardware we've just
bought a new box 15 kilo euros that's ok
as a budget it's got forty eight cores
almost 400 gigs of ram and seventy three
bites of storage and we designed that
storage quite well but that's not too
expensive in the surprising thing is
that we've got access to an 800 CPU
cluster so that's 200 knows I believe in
the kind of work that we do gets
actually done faster on this 15 kilo
yura box on which we've just installed
standard 12 then on the cluster that you
know that's 200 kilo euros and it
requires a sister that man and it's
dedicated a linux install it's all about
the access patterns at least in our use
case so that's kind of interesting and
we're not the first people to say this
does this great paper by microsoft
research that says nobody has ever been
fired for using hadoop on a cluster and
they show numbers like this so people
come in my office every day saying yeah
I want my code to be fishing on the
cluster well you know think about your
problems all right moving on we want to
avoid framework code your parallel
computing storage I'm gonna build a
framework that dispatches things oh the
problem with this is then it becomes
really hard to maintain each time you
get a new person you have to
in that person in the framework we
really want to avoid framework oh so
that's where job lid comes in and for
example we want to do parallel
processing the first thing I'm only
going to worry about embarrassing me /
halo 4 loops I'm not going to worry
about message passing problems wasted
too much time on this and your life is
too short to worry about that locks once
again I'm going to have to keep in mind
that what's going to condition the
efficiency of my my code is probably
going to give these things like data
access even on one single box because
the memory bus can very very easily be a
bottleneck so we're going to have to
find the right drain for polarization if
I'm do fine i'm going to get over hand
from it if I'm too coarse basically p
the workers are going to be computing
competing for for the data access so
this is droplet barrel this is all you
need to know to imports and then you
write a generator like expression and it
gets computed in parallel this is coming
openmp style parallelism so there's
nothing more right move on so first why
are we not using ipython
multi-processing celery MPI everything
jump lib is a higher level it's all a
different problem it solves that problem
right not all the problems that the
other things are trying to solve so
where's the value well one value is that
we have no dependency we don't even have
a dependency on multi-processing if you
don't have multiprocessing it won't fail
it just won't do parallel computing too
bad minor details that matter a lot like
we get better trays backs you know
debugging matters that's really so nice
Oh deviate implemented automatic men
mapping of arrays to be able to share
memory between processes because if I do
parallel computing chances are if I've
got big data I'm going to kill my memory
rather than killing my CPUs something
that's really critical is that we've got
on the flight dispatch of jobs so if
you're iterating over your parallel
you don't want to dispatch all your jobs
in the beginning and and then get them
back because you're going to chill your
memory if your jobs are or have memory
usage so that's kind of really tricky to
code actually the user doesn't see this
but it's really valuable and this is all
so new bio DJ's that we have a threading
or process back end and you know
yesterday linda was talking about random
forest in scikit-learn this is to any
Miller's Bosch that has apparently 32
cores this is what random forests now
look on this box so a hundred percent
cpu usage for everything it's actually
fairly challenging to get there to use
all your cpu's like this and on top of
this you can't see it because it's
really low but there's just about no
memory usage how did we get there it's a
lock free siphon code and threading back
in and the good thing is we can switch
from multiprocessing to threading back
in with only one keyword argument in
parallel so that the code evolves we
have more options this is nearly that's
a super excited how much talk about all
right I'm gonna skip this I'm going to
talk a bit about caching caching is
important for reproducibility I see
people when they do data analysis
there's just change scripts and then
they remember not to run this one
because the data hasn't changed I see
this all the time where they come and
outlined this is ridiculous thing and
reproducible and it's actually a problem
because when you get new data you can't
run your analysis you've got to manually
do it's also very important for
performance when you think about it not
computing something that you've already
computed it's just a crux of every
optimization and it's they're everywhere
it's during CPU pipelines it's there in
web applications so we're going to want
caching okay so that's easy there's the
memorized pattern you can find it on on
the bike own cookbook so we're just yeah
I'm sorry this is a bit low we're just
going to create a memory object and
test persistence to disk so we're going
to give it you know a path and then we
can use it to decorate a function
function f I'm going to decorate it into
flexion G and then the first time I call
function f on some object it computes
something the second time I called
function it it doesn't it's just
retrieved so that's you know trivial now
the difficulty is getting it right and
you know we're doing biggish data so a
and B can be pretty big so I want this
to work well with a and B bag and see it
could be cubic to from a design
perspective I want this to work all the
time therefore Andy can be arbitrary
Python object no control on what you're
putting in and on top of this I don't
want any dependencies because that's how
it works something new I've actually
discovered that it wasn't merged and
while doing this presentation so we need
to merge it in as this is giving us the
League of bricks for out of core are
computing so we now have a coin shelf
method on the decorated function that
will call the object the call the
function and not return of the result
because the result might take a lot of
memory so just stores it to disk and
later I just can call the get method on
this guy so then you know I can do
parallel computing and I'm only
returning these memorized result and
then I'm loading them as I need them so
we're starting to use it to process some
pretty big data in my lab and that's
really really simple pattern you're
almost not changing your code the only
thing is you've got to ride functions
people don't write functions my students
don't like to write functions well it's
the basic abstraction of reusable code
so it's a good thing I'm forcing you to
write functions I will not make a
context manager for joplin you know wave
memorize this will not happen so how do
we get this working well we're going to
be computing an md5 of sin avi hash of
the input argument why md5
gives its in the Python standard library
not because we like it so why why ash
what are their nasty because there's
super back boxing you know I can't look
at a hash I know the input argument the
thing is they're completely generic and
super robust you know if you don't get
hash collisions which don't really
happen you can just use it as a back box
and it will always work so people keep
telling me that they want something else
and then md5 hash in there i'm not sure
but i want something as a robust now
making it work as a challenge and this
is kind of a nice nice engineering part
so we're going to take an md5 hash of an
arbitrary object so we're going to
create an md5 hash objects that
something you just give it the attached
strings or beth thurs and in hash is
them and then we're going to step class
the Pickler from the standard library
and that thing is a state machine that
walks the object graph that's just the
way this look at the code it's brilliant
and then we're going to walk using this
step class we're going to walk the
object graph and then feed all these
objects to our md5 object little detail
is that when we find something that is a
memory of you are an NDA right we're not
going to convert it to string to pass it
to the md5 algorithm we're going to
simply give it the pointer to the data
so that's what makes it official that's
actually fairly efficient you'd be
surprised similar we want to persist
arbitrary object and instead of using
pickle we're going to sell off the
pickle and purse this differently and
fast things that are memory views or
numpy arrays and pickle the rest so we
get multiple files but the thing is
we're storing structured data as
structured data in an efficient way with
a parallel computing and a cash store we
might run into conclusory issues so i
tried doing the database way and that
didn't work because I did it wrong but
also because databases are what's tricky
to use them right with big arrays let's
say so
possible it's tricky so the way we're
doing this is that where you were
relying on a Tom make politics
operations so file a file system
operations and if they're failed with
just you know recompute whatever that's
got really good performance rate and
right and it's usable unshared this so
say clusters we want to make it fast so
how do we make it fast well we might be
able to use compression I had this
really interesting experiment where I
was loading processing data files and
then so I could zip them or not zip them
and when I was doing this on one core it
was faster not to zip the data file when
I was doing this on my 12 cores it was
faster to zippity to file big cares the
disk was the limiting factor not the the
CPU and it was significantly faster so
compression is definitely the way to go
we're using a zet lib not anything fancy
once again because it's in the standard
library so people you know last people
provide us with a great package
well-tested compressor and we might
optionally use it trick sorry need to
use on top of this we need to use the
compressor in an online way to avoid you
know blowing up memory so we avoid
copies by passing in directly the
buffers and also yeah one trick is that
we separate so we don't say transpose
arrays to make them see ordered we
passed a row buffer and we store the
strides and information that avoids a
copy and one thing that we're starting
to have is that when you're when you're
in the cluster and you've got 800 CPUs
hitting on a single storage something as
simple as opening a file gets really
really slow because you're triggering
locks in your in your file system so
we're starting to realize that actually
we need a single file dub not multiple
file dumps so we're revisiting this code
the challenge is it has to be done in a
streaming way to avoid you know blowing
up Thanks blowing out the memory usage
so taking a step back what matters
with aisle on ruining our systems the
number of bytes towards so that's where
compression kicks in if you know if
you're exchanging too many bytes are
going to bring your network of your SATA
bus down the memory usage if say one
you're storing or where you when you're
installing you used too much your memory
then you're computing nodes are going to
come down because they're going to run
out of memory and that's recent because
we're scheming app the number of atomic
file access and we're we're really
bringing or cluster down i'm not i'm not
kidding we're bringing a cluster down
with io walking it like annales takes
five minutes so when you scale out this
matters the way out of this is to have
this tribute it's real distributed
storage and nowhere to bring your
distributed storage down so it would be
things like not using politics I API so
basically so how do file system or
whatever in your SQL database but we
don't want to go down that way some
small benches I'm not going to go into
the details but basically this is to
tell you that we're pretty much as fast
as pie tables which uses a really cool
compressor because we've avoided memory
copies and were a bit careful with what
we do all right I said we wanted to
build an ecosystem and so we it's not
about you know building a program
building a script it's about helping
your future self that's going to come
back in five years and find that that
your code has grown so something that's
extremely important is to build a
community and so if you look at
scikit-learn we've got a huge feature
set this is the project growth over the
years and it's me it's exponential with
flattens we've more than 200
contributors proudly around 300 by now I
think 12 of these people are core
contributors bike or contributions I
mean they've coming access but they use
it on a daily basis weekly basis from
the start I would like to stress that
we've always had a full time in a
programmer
on this I'm just tracing this because
India has been we've got all our grant
applications have been rejected and me
has been taking on on its own money to
fund this I don't make these decisions
higher I've make this decision so
estimated cost of development from where
the really standard model is six million
huge what do we do this well because
code maintenance is expensive my mailbox
is a disaster look at that 53,000 unread
email and then going through my email I
find this this is a guy writing a
private email single ugh i can t is your
software account your reply to my email
i get this all the time so why do we
share software why we do we try to have
a community because our benefits only
come from tanya fraction of that code
data are loading did we care about data
and learning now we're not going to make
are vaccinated low ratings then
algorithms no we want them to be
available so we're going to share all
the common code and keep our precious
secrets else where we're going to die
under code thing is those secrets will
become less precious with time so
somebody might come up and encode
features and for instance in my group we
don't do random forests but it happens
instead the belch guys Belvin guys
really like random forests and so did
gene has come up and contribute to this
and then many people I've worked with
him and this is a tweet by gene that
shows across the different releases of
psychic learn our random force have
gotten much much faster I didn't have
anything to do with this this is
fantastic when the owning random force
there fast thanks to other people they
even do the figures for my key notes for
me awesome alright really quickly you
want to build a community driven project
you're going to have to think about it
you're going to think about your users
with dachshund examples use get up you
know don't use anything else really
important limit the technicality of your
code base else where you're going to be
the only one coding in it and really
focus on your contributors
credit there are the people doing this I
think we're doing something right and
this is a graph that shows you the
number of commits and different projects
for each contributor where the company
contributed number it doesn't mean
anything so what we're seeing is that
socket learn and this is normalized
there's no absolute value what we're
seeing is that the relative importance
of the commenters in scikit-learn it's
pretty good you know we're falling down
really stony we have many people and
contribute a lot and if you look at
other projects of some of them are in
big trouble one of them that's in big
trouble where is it this guy Miami my
unloved child so probably no I did a few
things wrong and one of them is the code
base is too technical and another one is
it took us ages to go to get that we
branded we didn't brand it right you
know we're getting exactly what we put
in tragedy of the Commons you know this
it's the ID that each individual is by
being rational not acting in the
community's interest and I think we're
seeing it because once we've making
things boring people move on to
something else I'm going to finish and
so cold projects are taken for granted I
think scikit-learn were really good but
non by contributions by contributors
nobody contributes to them fighting side
by you should look at the number of
people working in it everybody uses it
so if you're not contributing to these
projects at least remember they need we
need citations we need you know in
papers situs incorporate web pages tail
net way important because we're not even
getting funding we're not getting
funding people are telling us you're not
exciting you're not important all right
I'm going to finish important messages
the 8020 rules solve only the important
problems they're going to take twenty
percent of your time compared to solving
you'll never going to solve all the
problems to ramp up how do you be able
to
rate environment on a budget you set the
goals right you don't solve my problems
you use the simplest technological
solutions possible that actually
requires you to be very technically
savvy and not to use this cell
sophistication it took me a while to
realize this you focus on the human
factors both in your user base but also
need developer base if your developers
are happy they're going to be productive
that's pretty basic but it's really
important it really matters took me a
while to realize this and just to give
you an example of perfect design that's
a tetra pak you know it's a piece of
paper that you know contains milk it
Souls only the problem it was designed
to solve nothing else it's even got a
lid for the human factor so that you can
open it that's perfect design so you
want to aim for this you know simplest
as possible just works thank
the keynote we have time for two quick
questions do we have two quick questions
can you shout
we are checking in size and generated
code for good reasons people might
disagree but and cyclin generates a lot
of C code do we have one more question
one more question for it
there's no I find there's no difference
between organization and normal users I
think there is a fraction small finite
people who use your south river is going
to work on and contribute back it's
telling you so the only way you can get
more contributors is to get more users
now where you have to make your choice
right is that if you're going to you
know develop and then use the
application that's all you know cliquey
and everything you're not going to get
contributors for this that's why I'm no
longer doing graphical user interfaces
sorry people so some unfortunately some
unless mentalities completely changed
some problems won't will never get
solved but the way I go about this is I
try to not dumb down two much problems
so that my users might become
contributors and then have a as many
users as possible this is worked
everything else is failed ok we'll take
we're going to pick five minutes and
then we're going to start off the game
with James in here talking on generators
I remember that Peters talk has been
cancelled so to speak James talking in
here and later this afternoon she'll and
Peter will be talking on psychic learn
if you're interested to learn more
around some of this let's just thank
Gail again and then we'll take a break
you